the presence of great role models which
honestly I think like combined with the
fact that mi t--'s arts programs are
available to everyone and not just
people who are who have a sheet of paper
that says they're in an arts major those
two things like really helped me
personally and I think a lot of other
people too
my experience of getting or of doing
improvident I mean it or like
improvising when I sing jaws is just
like I think the first step is you just
have to get over yeah you have to get
over yourself
[Music]
improvisation is a good part of any
theater the the highest-risk
improvisation is during performances
when you know someone doesn't have
something they're supposed to have or
one light turns pink that looks really
fun one
I think it's really important to create
spaces that welcome failure because for
me like when I first jumped into art
like I was making things I had never
made before and obviously as an artist
as you grow you're definitely going to
look back on your past work and be like
wow that is honestly awful and infinite
and definitely those organization that's
what's happening and that's what's
allowing people to grow and continue to
allow new people to come in so that when
we leave there people who have grown and
outgrown and like can continue leading